ah here white wants to castle long so we
can bring the bishop back to f3
uh curtail the king from castling then
bring the knight back to d4 go e5 and
queen h4
it's it's over too many pieces in the
attack you can do it in whichever way
you want any questions
[Music]
here we go carolusk and let's play
another sicilian
d3 another semi-passive move
which is not particularly terrible
especially if it combines it with
fianchettoing the bishop
but if i doesn't then it's very very
passive so
you're welcome star polemic ceo so what
should we do here
nothing special we should just continue
developing as normal
and the move is knight c6
all right
knight c3 how should we proceed in this
position
there is a couple of good setups all of
them are good it
often depends on the type of sicilian
you play against the open sicilian
the um the most classic
method here is is the fiance of the
bishop fianchettoing the bishop
clamps down on the square you'll see how
that like five pieces have control over
d4
fianchettoing is awesome here the
alternative thing we could do is go e6
and d5 something i talked to charlie
just occupying the center with pawns but
i like fianchettoing i think i feel like
that's a little bit more in the sicilian
spirit
thank you robangi for the tier one
all right so knight f3 we fee and kettle
the bishop
mr hatsus it's not a bad opening to play
bishop d2
he continues to develop very passively
this is the ba well there's no name for
this specific sequence of moves
but when you put this knight on e7 it's
called the bombing setup
we don't need to do that here let's go
d6 and then develop our knight and sort
of
put on an accelerated accelerated dragon
setup
but of course in an improved version
because look at how passively he's
developed his pieces
once chess happens thank you so much
appreciate it
queen e2 so he's taking the basketball
and he's telegraphing the past what do
you think he wants
what is he going to do on the next move
very likely
well he's probably gonna castle he's
probably gonna castle
maybe he'll play e5 but that's not
dangerous we're in control of the square
we're in control of the e5 square bring
it on boy
bring on opposite side castling my man
because guess what this is this is a
bishop it's staring
right into the teeth okay g4 so he
starts by attacking or
making motions to attack our arcing
and at this point
and this is going to be hard for me to
explain but i'll make an attempt
you might be looking at this position
through your lens through your own lens
and say well white hasn't done anything
particularly bad
white's developed his knights okay he's
developed his bishop a little bit too
passively what's the big deal
okay he's put his queen out on e2 what's
the big deal
well the thing is it is a big deal
because we have developed
very actively in a way uh where our
pieces are coordinated
and we're already castled whereas
he has not developed in a way where his
pieces are coordinated the bishop is not
developed he's not castled yet
and by pushing g4 he's making he's
multiplying
the amount of weaknesses that he has so
in my mind i'm already basically looking
for crushing ideas i'm looking for ideas
that are just going to take the hammer
down
and and basically ban him
so what ideas might those be there's a
couple of ideas that
bring you on the path to that the
classic that some people have proposed
is to go rook to b8 and then push the b
pawn b5 b4 dislodging the knight
and widening the bishop's diagonal
another idea is to sacrifice on g4 but i
think that's maybe a little bit
premature
but guess what let's try it i want to
show you guys what happens
when you go a little bit crazy in these
types of positions let's play knight's
xg4
maybe it's unsound but guess what whose
stream is this
oh yeah that's right that's what i
thought
bishop takes g4
and you bow to the supreme leader
hearing on the discord
okay bishop h3 so what often happens
when you play in this kind of style is
that your opponent buckles almost
immediately
we have a pin against his knight as i've
told you guys before
what defines whether a pin is dangerous
primarily it is whether there is a pawn
which protects the pinned piece in this
case
there isn't in fact there's a queen on
e2 it is vulnerable
and as a lot of you guys are saying
knight d4 is the best
move it doesn't win the game he can take
our bishop and get
three pieces for the queen that's a lot
of minor pieces
but remember that we've also taken two
pawns and his king is going to be very
much exposed because the pawn cover
around it has been blown open
and we'll still be able to maintain our
fiance bishop
but three pieces for a queen is often
really really bad for the queen
in certain situations i can show you
guys a very memorable example
from one of my games where i went for a
position where i had a queen
thinking i have a queen for three pieces
i'm gonna uh you know i'm gonna crush
him and i just got
totally wiped off the board swindled a
draw in the end but
there's a funny story associated with
that that game as well
[Music]
so
all right i made temporary mods guys all
on mod respectively people i
modded to control uh the revolt
uh the kuda you know the coup d'etat
uh but we'll we'll discuss
more mods afterwards all right queen to
d1
and our opponent is not able to deal
with the situation
he prioritizes the queen which is a very
typical mistake
very typical mistake um
at this level where people you know the
concept of losing a queen is so scary
that they don't properly weigh
the pros and cons of giving up the queen
for three pieces
versus moving the queen away but losing
a bunch of other pieces
so should we take with the knight or
should we take with the bishop
a lot of you are saying bishop some of
you are saying knight both moves are
okay
knight takes f3 the king will go to f1
if you look very carefully there what
would be the best move
we are going to take with the bishop in
just a second because that wins the rook
but if we were to take with a knight yes
or yes after king f1
you would have only one good move in
that position
which would be not knight takes bishop
check because then the queen could just
take the knight
not knight takes d2 check but knight h
to check discover
check rook has to take the knight and
then you take the queen
but then white would have two pieces for
the queen it's not sufficient but at
least it's something
a full rook is generally going to be a
bit better than two pieces for the queen
although both are totally winning
i hope that makes sense let's take the
rook
and in addition we keep our pieces on
their dominant squares i think this
might just fast
this might lead to checkmate even faster
he might try to go here
so be prepared to see this membership f4
all right how do we finish this game as
fast as possible
well we need to think logically about
what's missing here and there's a couple
of ways to approach this we can ask
ourselves
which pieces can we involve in the
direct attack against the king
and if we ask ourselves that question
directly we might notice as some of you
are
that perhaps the queen could be made to
come to h4 by pushing the e pawn
but we don't even need that you might
also notice that the rook on f8 would be
a phenomenal attacker were
the file to open up let's open up the
file
now should you be worried about the
black king getting weakened here
who can answer that question to me why
well obviously the answer is no
conceptually why should you be totally
okay
with making a move like f5 in this
position well because you're up a rope
daniel obviously
but what's the more involved conceptual
reason
yeah so white is nothing on the king's
side right white is no no beef you're
alone in your
in your house whatever you can do
whatever you want you can put the movie
on loud
white doesn't have any firepower and
in addition to that you're still keeping
the fundamental integrity of your
king side protection this just isn't a
big deal
what is the big deal is the fact that
we're winning the queen and winning the
game
and he resigns good game well this guy
had the
joker avatar all right thank you
thuridius for the tier one let's look at
the game c5
d3 thank you amanda i appreciate it
knight c6
all right so
the best way for white to handle the
situation
is to play g3 and transpose into what's
called the closed
sicilian defense perhaps some of you
play it you fee encounter the bishop
and the point of the closest thing is
that you don't play d4 that's why it's
the closed the center remains
largely close it's it's a viable
anti-sicilian i used to play it
um i used to play it and
this would at least bring white into a
tenable position but the moment he
played knight f3 things start going
downhill bishop
d2 too passive just that this bishop is
not doing enough
so if you were to develop this bishop
maybe bishop b3 maybe bishop f4
somewhat better developing moves all
right d6
h3 well the open is considered to be a
more principled line right it's a better
it's a better chance at an advantage
than the closed sicilian
um but at a lower level there should be
no reason why the open is the most
popular i would say the alpine the
closed
they should be more heavily prioritized
by beginners intermediate players
than the open sicilian you know
so knight f6 and queen e2 is
asking for trouble right now
why is why is it that black should be so
happy to see
the move castles long well how should we
consider this
how should we think about this rather we
have this bishop on g7
the bishop is aiming at the b2 pawn
there's a lot of a lot of
bs that's sitting on this diagonal but
we'll take care of it
what do we need to do in this position
to jump start black's attack as quickly
as possible
well let's think logically if b2 is
going to be the pawn
that ultimately we pile up on how are we
going to do that well we might want to
open up the b
file so there's a move which meets all
of our goals and that's b5 we don't need
to prepare this move we can play it
immediately
if he doesn't take the pawn then we go
b4 dislodge the knight then follow up
with queen a5 if he does take the pawn
we follow with rook b8 we've opened the
file the knight has to move back
if white tries to support the knight we
can simply chase it away with a6 right
let's assume that white moves
immediately and now um
and now queen b6 comes with tremendous
effect
threatening checkmate if white pushes
the pawn on b3 the moment a move like
this is made
it creates holes this is what a lot of
people struggle with the concept of
being flexible when you're attacking
you've done the last three things
to attack b2 white has gone b3
the goal of the attack is no longer to
attack that pawn it's no longer there
you have to adapt to the change in
circumstances
to see how the circumstances have
changed and
that dictates the next course of the
attack so notice that the dark squares
have been weakened
primarily these squares what should we
do about that
what move would allow us to exploit that
so c4 would be unnecessary you don't
have to rip open the position further y
could play d take c4
we look for the lobster sword of the
lobster pincer boom i like queen b4
even queen a6 is kind of cool
we try to get to a3 with the queen b4
with the knight
and then something is going to come with
checkmate this is there is too many
threads here this is absolutely crushing
so is a5 significantly weaker than b5
yes
a lot of people consider pawn storms as
this monolithic thing
where you've got to move all three of
your pawns at the same time
i think where this comes from is you see
a lot of games in the
night or for sicilians or white is doing
this kind of thing
and you're assuming that in any position
you have to push two of your pawns at
once but that's not always true
because if you play a5 what's gonna
happen
well what is white going to do in this
position
there's a couple of things which are
wrong with this move the first is that
white can actually play a4
and say congratula well good luck
playing b5 now sir if you do play b5 and
i play knight takes b5 this knight is
sort of on an outpost
you'll get this knight off eventually
but it will buy white time
with which he will begin his own attack
right you gotta always tie it in
you don't have infinite time the other
thing is that even if white doesn't do
anything
and then stops you with a3 you've just
spent two moves
making very questionable progress
actually kind of locking up the queen
side
and there's really no reason why you
should have done that
so what you need to understand
is that the point of most pawn storms
is to open up avenues for your pieces
there are two conclusions which stem
from that the first
is pawn storms are sometimes unnecessary
there are situations where you already
have so many pieces in the attack
that you simply do not need to advance
upon you can directly you can use your
pieces
in the capacity of pawns you can
sacrifice a piece
to open up the pawn structure around
your opponent's king rather than using
your pawns that can be a better use
of time or if you are using your pawns
you don't always have to advance them in
pairs you can
advance just one pawn you can sacrifice
a pawn
uh it's not about you know advancing two
or three pawns
in synchrony remember that your end goal
is
usually to rip open your opponent's king
i know that was a whole speech but this
is very often misunderstood
a lot of my students when we start going
over attacks
and it's interesting for me to see this
they will always attack and
try to attack in the same way first
they'll start with a pawn storm the pawn
storm looks exactly the same way
a lot of people here would um would
propose a move like a5
or a6 and b5 which is understandable
but you got to be flexible with pawn
storms
all right if the knight doesn't take b5
then you go b4
and then a move like queen a5 would be
devastating because this pawn is not
easy to defend
after a3 black has many good moves can
you guys spot a particularly sexy move
here
well attacking is one of the hardest
ghosts to master attacking properly is
is a lifelong lifelong journey
the move is um the move is b takes a3
ladies and gentlemen
moves b takes a3 like what bishop takes
queen
you're blundering your queen but this
pawn comes out to a2
uh ladies and gentlemen how are you
stopping a1 queen
after which that newly promoted queen is
going to be in a beautiful position it's
going to have a
apartment in central manhattan from
where it can
attack b2 to its heart's content
all right good let's turn to the game
itself
now when we do this
the immediate threat is is d4 so
how should white respond in this
position
the actual correct move here well it's
hard to find
it's hard to i think the correct move is
quite hard to understand why it's good
because it doesn't directly stop knight
d4 it doesn't directly stop knight four
but it takes the sting out of it
yes uh thoridius absolutely um
in just a second the tempting move is
queen e3
but after queen e3 knight d4 you're in a
tough spot black is threatening two
things at once
takes takes forking the queen and the
knight
correct move is simply bishop g2
knight d4 queen d1 and the knight is
actually well defended i'm not sure
what's going on here perhaps black can
play f5 to open the f file
but i wasn't sure how to evaluate this
so if we check the computer
the eval is oh i can't check the
computer because i don't have a
premium membership here so it's it's
double-edged
i'm not entirely sure this is sound but
you can see that white can
can more or less stay alive
how did you sense the night stack would
work well it's pattern recognition i've
seen this kind of sack
a million times where do i see it a
million times
particularly in openings like the
italian i'm sure you guys have seen this
bear with me for i'm sure a lot of you
have seen this before and it's all about
transferring the patterns have you seen
a position like this before
knight takes g4 same concept this knight
is not defended by a pawn
same types of threats like queen f6 and
knight t4 come in
white can do the same thing in many
positions so it's actually not that much
different it's just that it's
it's you do this for a different reason
uh but the mechanism is the same this
knight is vulnerable
black species are very strong so that
makes the pin
even stronger and
after bishop h394 he should have taken
on d4 which leads to a position like
this
three pieces for a queen and two pawns
black is better but why can
the game continues here let me quickly
explain passive development yeah
alternative to knight takes g4
rook b8 and b5 b4 same planet as before
would have been great
d5 striking in the center would have
been a good idea knight d4 is
interesting too
lots of possible moves here i would have
probably played rook b in
a classical game alright
so what does the word passive mean in a
chess context
it's another one of those wishy-washy
terms
which doesn't have a very clear
definition also it's not always bad it
has a negative connotation
it shouldn't always have a negative
connotation because sometimes you have
to play passively
so passive and active right it's more
that you have a mental picture of what
an active move looks like a move that
does a lot of stuff
an active piece is a piece that has a
lot of good rolls a passive piece is a
piece that's sort of crouching
near the corner of the board or near the
first ranks
without much justification so this
bishop is a great example
of of a passive piece in conjunction
specif particularly with the fact that
the other bishop
is restricted by the pawn so literally
black's pieces are controlling
so much more real estate in the center
than white's pieces are
i hope that kind of makes sense i hope
that kind of makes sense
um and i'll flesh this out more in the
future
but i want to first show you guys an
example
of where i misjudged a situation where i
could grab my opponent's queen for three
pieces
and got absolutely crushed as a
consequence
except i drew because of a miracle but
that's less important
so a quiet move yes so there are two
completely different things
a quiet move is a move that doesn't pose
an immediate threat
generally speaking a passive move could
pose a threat
although often times they don't a
passive move refers to
the quality of the if that makes sense
whereas a quiet move refers to the
quality of the move and what threats it
creates
quiet move doesn't tell you much about
the piece that you're moving
but rather what you're threatening
passive slash active tells you
not so much what you're threatening but
rather the quality of the piece the
position of the piece
that's a good may be a good way to think
about it
all right a quiet move could be passive
or a quiet move could be um
could be active there they're on two
separate planes
a couple of stories in relation to this
game which was played in 2010 in
budapest
this tournament was a nightmare well the
good tournament was also a nightmare
so 2010 uh
i hadn't been to europe that many times
i was a feed a master my rating was 2403
but i didn't have any im norms so i hit
2400 before i got a single i am norm
um not like uh some of the some of these
kids now
so i'm flying to budapest uh where there
is a very famous tournament called first
saturday
it's a norm tournament there's it's
conducive to a nor to getting a norm
and i'm at the airport with my mom and
we're checking into the flight
and we hand the passports to the ticket
agent and
he looks at the password and looks at us
and says uh excuse me
but your passport's expired oh my god
and
this is three hours before the flight to
hungary
and two days before the tournament
starts so
uh because of the stricter requirements
we had to go to the passport agency
cancel the flight spend the entirety of
the passport agency then
fly fly into the tournament literally on
the same day of the first round the
morning of the first round
and this is a 14-hour journey so i'm i'm
absolutely
exhausted i somehow draw the first game
against the strong i am but and i play
the best tournament of my life i beat
everybody i gain an i am norm with
two rounds to spare i get a night well
you only need to play nine games for an
i am norm
and as you can see this is round 11. so
after nine rounds i had an im norm
i drew the tenth game and 11th game i'm
playing to win the tournament
and i'm playing grandmaster for garagey
uh i need to draw the game to win the
tournament
so i'm preparing before the round i have
some iced tea sweet iced tea that i'm
drinking
while preparing and of course the iced
tea is
spilled all over the keyboard of my
laptop this is
right before the game so i'm freaking
out but i have to go to the game so i
play this
game with a laptop in the back of my
head uh
the laptop was fine in the end but
it was quite the experience anyways so
this is a night off
and already in this position
i decided to play the move b5 and
this is a typical night or move except
if you have a keen eye
you might notice that it allows an x-ray
against the rook which
white immediately exploits by playing e5
does this win the game
well it might seem that way because it
attacks the knight it attacks the rook
but what's the catch here
what does black have in this position
this actually constitutes a typical idea
in these sicilians
this is not unusual bishop b7
developing counter-attacking the queen
i'm doing great
i thought were fine what do you think my
opponent did in this position
this is actually very bad for black oops
wrong cup
okay
all right so the move is he takes f6
wait a second he's blundering his queen
well let's think a little bit too
a little bit further bishop f3 boom
attacking the rook boom boom
so we have a position where white has
three pieces for the queen
but look at the state of black's king i
can't
castle this way i can castle this way
but i've already pushed these pawns out
so and i can remain in the center but
the e-file is a semi-open file
so no matter where i go white has four
minor pieces
that's so much stuff more than enough
stuff
to essentially massacre black skin
wherever i go
or don't go and what happens is that i
tried to put out this little pawn shell
my opponent breaks it down so easy i
mean look at this square
and we get i mean this is this is the
worst position of all time
look at the domination of the three
pieces against the queen
by an absolute miracle i created insane
chances
in typical naredinsky style i played
with rook c3 here
trying to sack a rook to create chances
and i drew the game somehow
uh that's less interesting my opponent
blunted in the end
but i just wanted to show you guys that
three pieces for a queen is a very
interesting imbalance
which needs to be evaluated on a
case-by-case basis that's the conclusion
here
um anyways no respect for the dark
squares at all
folks at all all right
phenomenal did he take the rook no he
did not he did not take the rook
but let's go back to the speed run
all right so
that's basically that um once he
didn't take the knight the game was over
bishop f3 bishop h1 upper rook
and winning the game any questions about
the game
well the three pieces can work together
they can cover more squares than the
queen
they can cooperate better in an attack
it's a combination of things
that taken together uh that taken
together
can make them overwhelm the queen quite
easily in certain positions
so had he not blundered his queen and
taken on f5
what should we take this pawn with
what should we take this pawn with
ladies and gentlemen
the knight the knight because we want to
open the f file
and it's okay to bring the knight back
temporarily we'll bring it back to d4
later
and we'll have the file open all right
and we can then play e5 so let's say
white plays queen d2 now we go
ah here white wants to castle long so we
can bring the bishop back to f3
uh curtail the king from castling then
bring the knight back to d4 go e5 and
queen h4
it's it's over too many pieces in the
attack you can do it in whichever way
you want any questions